[Musique]
mais enfin c'est pas possible qu'on soit
plus jamais toi et moi tu étais sur un
jeu sûr que tu
[Musique]
tu répondras que je t'appelle tu
m'emmerdes tu comprends tu m'en vais les
ouïes beau jeune homme que j'ai
rencontré il ya 35 ans celui qui voulait
changer le monde a fait tellement cru
que j'y crois plus tu m'énerves mais ta
gueule un manager du lady di avec ta
tranche de thouars tu vas me faire peur
simmons simmons simmons
[Musique]
oui simonov veut pas devoir
se comprend jay baer
vous êtes bien foutus de ma gueule ça
m'a ouvert les yeux tu sais que tu t'en
ailles ça m'a ouvert les yeux ouverts
je reste ici je suis enfin paisible
[Applaudissements]
en fait une merde les avoir tous les
deux qu'on après j'ai toujours su
à
non
j
tu es lumineuse c'est les lampions